In this lecture, we introduce
the Poisson process, which is
a continuous time analog of
the Bernoulli process.
One way of thinking about
it is as follows.
Time is continuous, but
conceptually we divide it into
a very large number of slots.
And during each slot,
we have a tiny
probability of an arrival.
This probability is proportional
to the
length of the slot.
Furthermore, we have an
independence assumption for
the different slots.
The Poisson process is a very
elegant model of arrival
processes in continuous time.
It models many real-world
phenomena.
And it also has a very clean
mathematical structure that
allows us to calculate
practically
every quantity of interest.
Our development will parallel
our analysis of
the Bernoulli process.
For example, we will find the
PMF of the number of arrivals
during a time interval
and the PDF of the
time of the kth arrival.
We will discuss the
memorylessness properties of
the Poisson process.
Similar to the case of the
Bernoulli process, this is
just a consequence of the
independence assumptions that
we are making.
We will then exploit these
independence properties to
argue that the interarrival
times are independent
exponential random variables.
And we will conclude with
a comprehensive example.